or like your brain is really attuned to those happy paths and what should we call the non-happy
path i keep i was trying to think of that the unhappy path the bad path the evil path the sad
path the sad path has a good ring to it best path of hacking when you can just you know critical
thing right already my dude this i think is one of my favorite episodes of the year every year
we just get 10 awesome pieces of research deep dive it figure out what has been at the top of the web
hacking world in this past year it's a fun one to record for sure yeah i mean it's the highest
total like value per time of any episode i'd say yeah yeah for sure um but before we and we got a
lot to cover we got a lot to cover and not a lot of time to do it today so i'm not sure if we're
going to make our deadline that's in like an hour here or not um but before we hop into it i gotta
say man i have had my head deep in a bug this week deep deep and actually so much so so much so that
when i message you my wife is like is justin okay she legitimately asks me to text you and say just
ask justin if he's okay dude i just you know sometimes when you get a vuln it's like you just go
go go at it like and and to be honest it only normally happens during live hacking events where i go
this deep right but this is the first time in a while where i've been like i will exploit this bug you
know it probably helped that last week you got multiple like 10k bounties from them right that
that did help but but you know you you go up against a target and you're like you know keep
hitting wall after wall after wall but then you just gotta like make it happen you know and and this
was one of those times and finally after like 30 hours messing with this like it might be a high
you know like it's not even a crit is it because of user interaction is that why yeah yeah well the user
interaction is required for sure um but it's like you know there's just a monstrous chain and a new css
it's a css injection and you know of course and of course i had to come up with like this new css
exfiltration technique that i'll eventually post about um but man it feels good it feels good to
literally what i did joseph was i i took my phone i took all of my notifications i just said i'm putting
it on do not disturb until i solve this bug no way and i i didn't look at any of the messages it went
across multiple days yeah dude multiple days this is three days i didn't touch a single notification
or or a single item on my to-do list it was painful but i loved it and i got it and i got
the bug so you know that's amazing i'm gonna uh share it later in the episode but i'll go ahead
and give them a preview right now that i think we work in the best industry by far oh and it's for
reasons like that right yeah dude it's so it's so easy to like just get lost in it you know once once
i allow myself to do it and and for the past like couple months i used to get lost in a lot as a full-time
hunter right um but for the past couple months you know i've i've had critical thinking i've had
kaido stuff i've had all sorts of stuff sort of pulling at me left and right mentorship and um and
man it felt good to just put everything on do not disturb and just say screw it i'm not responding to
anything until i i complete this bug yeah do you think do you think you would have eventually popped
it if you hadn't done that i don't know dude i don't know i we probably hit we probably hit four or
five different like uh we're done you know walls uh on this bug and pushed through um so i think i
think it required the amount of focus that it got and to be honest man maybe i'm a little optimistic
but i feel like most bugs are that way where like after a while after you kind of um you know and this
is probably just me being hyper confident but like if if you put enough time and effort into it you can
kind of bend the application to your will you know um i don't know maybe that's too optimistic we're
struggling with another bug right now so we'll say see how that one pans out maybe that's the case when
you have uh application and interconnected applications that are as complicated as google does then maybe
you're right right but there are just some applications that are so simple that it's like if
if there's no gadget there's no gadget right yeah dude i don't know we we did uh you know and shout
out to integrity they rock um but you know when when they did the live hacking event uh in in um
portugal last year or maybe it was the year before um one of the one of the pieces of scope that they had
was like real small and most people were focusing on other things because of that um and and i was like
nah i'm gonna focus on this guy you know and and and after staring at it for long enough i came up with
this like wonky you know client-side path reversal chain that that had some some actual impact so yeah
you know they're they're small applications minimal scope you know it's disappointing sometimes but
there's something there there's something yeah yeah i feel it all right well we got like you said not a
lot of time yeah tight on time but but before we get into it i do want to hear about this ai blog post
you put out and and the master class you're going to run on it because i i saw it yesterday i skimmed it
but with all of the research that we needed to read for this episode i didn't get to read it so so
tell me sure yeah yeah i'll give everyone the 30 second overview basically i have been asked
hundreds of times to tell someone like to just answer the question of how do i get started with
hacking ai stuff and i think that there's also this huge um gap of like basically bug hunters that want
to be able to hack ai and they're kind of confused about what is ai safety what is ai security and then
you know what security vulnerabilities can exist in certain chat apps and what kind of
interactions exist there and i wanted to have like one de facto zero to hero style guide and i think
there's going to be you know tons more content like this as as it goes on and i'll keep updating it if
there are any like new breakthroughs or anything but i think at least for for months and maybe for a year
or two this should be all you need to go from zero to hero dude so yeah and so it's a living document
yeah i'm definitely going to add to it as we go um especially some of the tools that are coming out
uh hadix is dropping some cool stuff in one of his things but um yeah i'm doing a three-hour master
class on march 11th at like 9 a.m pacific 12 noon eastern it's only 200 bucks i wanted to make it
super accessible it will be 90 of the content from the blog so if you can't afford it or don't care just
read the blog but there are a lot of people who learn better better with like a you know visual medium
and then also there'll be like live q a and i may talk about a few bugs i found so sweet dude that
sounds awesome yeah i definitely definitely need you know ai definitely needed something like that where it's just a kind of a
a playbook to go after those i think it'll be really helpful if you're using ai to help understand or
attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app
or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack
an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app
an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app or attack an app
you know ai definitely needed something like that where it's just a kind of a playbook to go after
those i think it'll be really helpful if you're using ai to help understand or attack an application
you can just copy and paste the whole blog in there and then use that as like the ideation to basically
kind of teach the llm in that moment what what you're trying to achieve using ai to teach ai how to attack
yes but but really though i mean i do think like you know all of us love copying and pasting in huge
context into into these uh large language models right now and i think you'll be perfect for that
one thing i did want to say was uh that critical thinkers do have like a 50 off code so for the for
the teaching there so maybe you can like pay 35 to save a hundred dollars yeah exactly that's great
that's a good idea all right so with that let's jump right into the content port swagger top 10 of 2024
um each year port swagger uh puts together a panel and takes nominations for the top web
research of the past year and uh to be honest it's one of my most uh anticipated blog posts of the
year i think because um it just pulls together a lot of really good resources even the nominations
list is like phenomenal um and then you know what we do here at critical thinking is we take that list
and we digest each one of them um and in the past actually uh joseph what we've done what i did with
joel in the past was then we would then provide our top 10 out of your re-ranked it you know we order it
i we didn't do that this time i don't know if we'll fit that in at the end we may like pause and
then deliberate or whatever but um uh the the submissions this year were thank goodness not as
uh like cumbersome as last year dude like last year i think there were like four or five out of the 10
were like 50 page research papers oh my goodness so joel and i like sat down and we had to allocate
like 20 hours yeah yeah more dude like it took multiple days of prep to kind of get through that
whole episode yep but dang i learned so much um just to close the loop do you know if they commented
on if anybody voted for that thing that said do not vote for this oh i don't know i don't know
actually i didn't know if they tweeted about it somewhere or something yeah yeah but the to be
honest i was looking at the top 10 this year um we see an odd amount of like write-ups like like you
know vulnerability write-ups rather than like this is a new uh uh technique to attack applications um
which you know i'm not going to complain about i love a good write-up just as much as anybody else
um but i do think that uh it would be cool to have a research top 10 and a write-ups top 10 because
there are some amazing write-ups out there that you that chain together like a bunch of really just
commonly known and pretty rare gadgets to into a beautiful masterpiece um and then there's stuff
like you know james kettle's http request smuggling right she's like here's a new vuln class you know
um so do you think they're kind of mixed together here do you think that uh that means we'll have an
an inordinate amount of research this next year because if you think about if there's a lot of
people who just didn't make the cut right they didn't get the chance to publish the research or what
have you and they were working on it the last year it'll probably get published in 2025 so i would
expect probably a greater number of like kind of novel pieces of research this year
shit dude every other year we're gonna have a 20 hour prep session for these uh ports worker top 10
maybe so maybe so yeah maybe um all right well let's dive right into it um we kind of diced them up uh
in divvied them out um so i think i've got one then you've got two that i've got two so i'll go ahead
and start with this number 10 and we'll work our way down to number one um and the the number 10 on
the list was hijacking oauth flows via cookie tossing thank you for giving me this one uh joseph you
know because we kind of did the draft a little bit yeah and um and i was hoping i'd get this one because
i love to talk about cookies and cookie tossing um and you know to be honest this uh this write-up is
like a pretty great primer on cookie tossing and why it's awesome um the the author sort of goes through
and talks about what is cookie tossing how do cookies work what are the the cookie attributes
and for anybody who who isn't familiar with uh with cookie tossing the concept behind that is
that when you set a cookie you have the ability to set um well first if you're not familiar with it
you're not listening to the pod enough because we've talked on about it a lot um but in these
attributes you have the ability to specify a domain and a path for this cookie okay the domain is
the domain to which the cookie will be sent and the path is the path to which the cookie will be sent
well there's this really awesome combination that you can do where you set the domain uh not to a
subdomain like www.google.com but to dot google.com or whatever right um and that will send it to every
subdomain of google.com and any subdomain of google.com in this scenario has the ability to set a cookie
like that and they can also set a cookie with a specific path now this this joseph is where the
rub happens here this is well i have a quick i have a quick question when it comes to cookie tossing do
you normally actually have control of some sort of parameter that's then controlling it or is it like
um something different like you know what's the mechanism about what you typically can't control this
it's typically you know semicolon injection like there you know you control the value of a cookie
right so maybe there's some cookie state equals and then you provide a value by a query parameter
and what they're doing is they're taking that that value and they're just putting it you know directly
into a cookie and they're not checking for the semicolon which is the what we've talked about in
the past and sort of deemed as partial cookie injection where you control um you can break out of the cookie
value context and go into the cookie attribute context right right um and so if you do that then you
gain control of these primitives you know uh domain equals and and path equals that allows you to
specify a specific domain and a path um and the reason why that's interesting is because you can
make your cookie get priority um meaning be sent first to the web server by specifying a more specific
path for your cookie so let's say there's two two cookie prim or two cookie two state cookies right
and one of them has no path set and one of them has path to uh you know slash yeah slash app or slash
initiate auth right your your more specific path even if the domain is wider is going to actually be
given uh priority and and that's sort of the whole concept behind this this cookie tossing research um
and you know the the author kind of gives a couple scenarios where uh this is this is helpful um one is
in this sort of uh sea surf like situation so uh what you can do with this so let's say you got an xss on
like blah blah blah subdomain.com right um and you use that to set a a cookie and uh for the domain and
specify a very specific path now as the user is going around in the application let's say that there's
like a update address function or something like that right um and it's there's no c-serve protections
on it but it's json content type so you can't c-serve it right um and you set your attacker session
cookie for that update address path right yeah so when the user goes in there to update their address
and their browser sends a request to the server with their user data their address um our cookie
will be given will be attached to that request only for that specific path so just for that specific path
the user is logged in as the attacker yep and it will set it as your address so you can view it
exactly exactly so you can exfiltrate data that way it's sort of like a c-serve but it doesn't
actually happen to the victim's account it actually happens to your account but that's bad for the
victim right you know sort of situation um and this is a very very similar technique to what uh was
was discussed with matan um in in episode geez i had it somewhere it was like i wonder if that exists
anywhere um when you're generating api keys because that would be the most that would be like kind of
the coolest well maybe we don't maybe we don't like generate it maybe we'd only generate it for
the attackers off and so maybe it wouldn't matter but um that feels impactful the well and actually
what happened in the article was sort of something similar which was um linking a a github account
um and so what they had a callback where you you could link a uh a github account um you know to to
your flow or to to your uh account in the app and so when you go through the flow and it comes back and
it links your account uh that's when the attacker fixated their session to that specific path so it
actually leaked the victim's github account right to the attacker's account and then you could access
all their like github information right um so there's lots of cool ways to exploit this also of
course uh self xss as we talked about in the episode with matan um which we'll link in the description
uh but definitely a really cool write-up uh over here from sneak and um there's a really awesome
youtube video also that i just tweeted out about it that's a really good primer to cookie tossing so
if any of you listeners are aspiring to master the cookie tossing technique then i think that would be
my go-to resource um to check out yeah i had a thought a minute ago that i forgot to ask um is
this something that is often detectable in like a um a deterministic way where you could have like
a plug-in for kaido or whatever that actually will just highlight things where the cookie is able
no because you have to find the vulnerability it would be like it would be like you need a reflection
like like the partial cookie injection is definitely um detectable you know you can check the query
parameters and then if it's if it's and then the set headers header yeah i'm sorry set cookies header
mm-hmm yeah yeah set cookies or if it's but it can also happen on the client side okay with document
dot cookie right so it's it's a little bit tricky to get fully i think sure cool you want to go on
to the next one yeah yeah take it away sweet yeah so the next one is chat gpt account takeover and you
know i took this one just uh in the theme of uh my career path so so i i think i ended up taking it
second or third in the draft um the the listeners will learn what i picked first uh since you gave
me first pick as we as we go along but um yeah so this research is from wow what is actually the
name how do you pronounce that no i have no idea dude no kind harrell search uh security research but
it's really cool i actually wonder if it made top 10 just because the word chat gpt was in the title
it's fantastic research i'm not saying that but just you know where ai is like so popular i wonder
if people saw that and kind of were more likely to vote for it but it's really neat i think um
honestly i relearned cache deception like you know twice a year i don't really use it much and then
when i read about it's like oh yeah this is how it works uh it definitely feels like something that
could be um detected or at least highlighted by uh specific tools to find them i'm sure lots of
people have written those but yeah it'd be great if someone would write one of those for kaido
and so yeah cache deception for anyone i'm not up to speed or in case we have some new
listeners is basically where you're like uh caches are very very useful for loading static content
such as javascript files or images or whatever stuff that's not going to change and it's totally
safe to do so but anytime you are able to cache someone's data like someone else's data or i guess
you're always mostly going to be caching your own data at an endpoint then someone else can browse
their attacker can browse there or they can kind of force you to click a link or it's kind of like rxss
where you click a link it caches your data then the attacker browses to that same link and your data
shows up because it's cached and so this vulnerability exists anytime a company is caching a a path or a
route or an endpoint that hosts sensitive data when they shouldn't be and so you can detect that with
the header um you know it's a for cloudflare specifically it's cf dash cache dash status but it's
it's always called um hit is usually the header hit or miss is typically what you see yeah yeah and then you
can see that dynamic as well right yeah do you look for these much that was one thing i was going
to ask you was whether you look for cache reception much yeah i i um i haven't looked at it as much i
mean i've definitely reported you know probably 10 of these uh on hacker one uh in the past but i think
it was something that i was focused on a little bit more back in like 2023 um and i haven't reported
them quite as much um over the past couple years so it's something that i need to pay attention to and i
do think that since it is something that's happening over http it is particularly well suited you know
without a lot of client-side interaction um i think it is particularly well suited for like a kaido
plug-in or something like that to sort of detect what could be going on there um and there's definitely
an amazing uh set of research that came out uh at defcon this past year that we covered in the defcon
episode uh from the port swigger research team on like crazy ways to get stuff cached um so that that
definitely goes in in uh in conjunction with this really well and would be a good place for anybody
who wants to sort of get up to date on this uh on this full type does this happen uh so i was going
to ask you this as well i didn't know if any in any of that research they mentioned does this happen
as like a cloudflare misconfig or does this actually happen on the server where they've written a piece
of code that determines where it gets cached or determines what gets cash it's a little bit of
both sometimes you know depending on the configuration but a lot of times it's it's the
the the problem of the caching proxy uh so whatever is causing causing the cache you've got it
misconfigured in such a way that it will cache you know based off of uh url extension with a wildcard
something yeah exactly and and so if you you know one of the one of the most common ones you'll see is
like aspx has this really liberal um path uh delineations like it just if you hit whatever
dot aspx slash abc dot css then it always just is like okay that's just the aspx file you know um and
then if but it looks like that file ends in dot css so the the caching server is like all right i'll
cache that yeah um and so yeah and i think one of the other things that mentioned in this article was
that this is actually really commonly done with um path traversals as well so the excuse me my throat
just gave out on me um so the author here uses percent 2f dot dot percent 2f in this uh write-up
you know to to make it look like the um path is actually under slash share which should be a cacheable
endpoint um but then proceeds to do the path traversal because the server is processing percent 2f as a
directory delineator a directory delimiter um and that's what what sort of was able to cause the
vulnerability to occur yeah if someone wrote this um tool like a tool specifically for this i would
say they should like always check for slash js percent 2f dot dot percent 2f because you know
javascript files are going to frequently be cached similar if there's like a slash assets slash images
do it there as well and so you can kind of check for all of those separate things yeah so what they did was
uh for this they were able to cache um like justin just said it was caching shared content so in chat gpt
at least at that time you were able to share a a you know a thread or a ai response and the links were
always like slash share slash chat uu id and so they were caching everything there and i was actually
going to ask you is this considered client side path traversal or just gonna just a standard one it's kind of
weird like it it's more like a like a secondary context thing right where we're like there's a um
there is a server somewhere along the line that's not the cache server that is processing that percent
2f as a as a directory delimiter um and that's why they're able to cause this whole thing um yeah yeah
that's fair yeah yeah because like yeah the caching server is not normalizing the path but then the
backend server is normalizing it exactly and one of the one of the things that i think would be really cool
from a research perspective or somebody that wants to make a plugin or something like that is to
figure out a way to inform hackers in a meaningful way what the different application segments are and
what kind of headers are being respond responded within this area right because the reason why this
worked in this scenario is because there's there's caching um configured for the the slash share
you know section of of chat.openai.com um and so if there's if there's a good way for us to
sort of understanding like oh okay over here doesn't have coop headers over here doesn't have
extreme options headers over here seems to be caching stuff that sort of information is really
valuable to us and i think is not really formalized in a way that's very readable at this point yeah do
you think there's maybe some sort of visualization based plugin or software where like yeah you know
as you're hacking on a website it's like kind of learning like you said the different context and
drawing it and just like a very simple like you know tl draw style thing where it's like this and this
yeah yeah that'd be good that could that could be cool and to be honest maybe it would be even
easier to do you could just say like cache segments extreme options and no extreme option segments and
then provide the like highest level path that does not have that header you know present in the response
and it's a little bit tricky because like sometimes 404s have different headers and you know but it is
interesting for sure yeah well maybe maybe it would only do it for um requests that actually are exist
in the sitemap so then you don't have to worry about 404s and 500s and that sort of thing because
like yeah i mean if you brute force that or checked it then of course you would deal with those issues but
if you were just looking at what actually exists in the natural browsing history it would be much more
likely to be real um yeah so so that little piece of path traversal actually made it what's called a
wild card cache deception because you could you could basically go to any path to cache it um yeah and then they
uh reported it and this was uh shortly after open ai started their bug bounty uh program and they paid
6500 for it all right cool so what's this one next we got oauth non happy path to ato you know i'm
actually really glad they put happy path in the title because that was one of the coolest things that i
took from this rereading this i'm like man i just love the idea of a happy path i think it's something
that we all mentally do who've been in like the hacking game for a little while it's like you have to
understand how that application works normally so then you can understand when things are kind of
weird and that understanding normally is actually a really key piece and i think it's probably a
reason why spending a lot of time on a single program can often pay off because now you know
all of those happy paths and um you know you don't always know what the no's are in an application as
douglas day always mentions and i think by understanding the happy path you can see all those
no's pop out because your eyes are uh or like your brain is really attuned to those happy paths and what
should we call the non-happy path i keep i was trying to unhappy the bad path the evil path the
sad path the sad sad path has a good ring to it so the sad path makes the developers sad because they
have to pay us a bounty so um yeah so when i was reading this one it's called oauth non-happy path to
ato by orx or oxrz and so um he's working on a public bug bounty program um it looks like the happy path
yeah he calls it not how you pass the happy path and sad path actually somehow or the happy path
comes from wikipedia and he got the non-happy path from our boy franz rosens right up so love it um
probably dirty dancing yeah it is dirty dancing so the cool thing here that um there are a couple
for you know key cool takeaways we have had an entire episode on oauth so i'm not going to break
all that down again but i wanted to mention a couple of these quotes um so one is i try to change the
response type parameter from code to id token i don't know if we covered that on that oauth episode
but i thought that was a really uh cool technique and then they mentioned later um because there's
like three different forms of oauth that this app supported that um that is not possible with github
with logging with github and it's not possible facebook has this kind of interesting um thing where
you have to like click to continue as the user which changes the refer header so that ended up not
being exploitable either um and then kind of the combination of using the id and the token thing
here is that google allows you to pass multiple response types so you can do id token or code or
comma separate them right they both work yeah and then uh this actually it feels like might be you know
hx01 is a decent friend of ours he hasn't made that much noise lately but he's still doing bug hunting i
was talking to him recently he's found a lot of issues in oauth with google logging with google
implementations and i wonder if this is why because kind of some of the stuff they support
from a complexity perspective so with response type id token or comma or code you still end up at a page
where you as that we're all familiar with where you select which account to log into which then breaks
the refer part of this of his payload but um then this part this part was something that i thought
would be really highly valuable to all of our listeners if you use prompt equals none as a parameter
um then users who are previously logged into google it bypasses that page and i think just logs you
in with your primary which i never knew you could even do that yeah that's a super useful gadget i've
used that many times okay well maybe it's maybe it's much more common for for the for the hackers
you know you see it at live hacking events or like i've kind of done a couple deep dives on a walk
before but it is it is super helpful and i think the the changing the response type also like
uh because if i'm if i remember correctly it ends up in a fragment still right it doesn't end up in a
in a like a query parameter um with when you provide multiple of those uh of those values there at least
it possibly can um yeah that's which is super helpful for being like okay well i still need the
code because that's how i redeem it on the application but i i want it in a different format so it's not
consumed as soon as it comes to the page and thus it's in the fragment why would they ever support comma
separate response type i have no idea okay because because like when i was reading this i'm like
i'm why that just that feels like there's something google should fix because it seems like even using
the analogy of happy pass really powerful way to explain this basically even if there are multiple
happy paths like you would never want a user to be able to go down two paths at once it doesn't make
any sense for logging in it's like you're logging in one way or you're authenticating a different way
you can't do both at once and google's like yeah you can do both at once yeah yeah i'm not really
sure what what use there is for that because typically you're swapping the code anyway for a
token um on the server side so um yeah not sure what's going on there but it is definitely a helpful
gadget and and can help you map out those unhappy paths for or sad paths or whatever we're calling them
for for a watch flows which is very helpful for getting atl yep sweet that is all i had if you want
to roll us into number seven sweet dude okay we we're dude all right we're doing it we're doing pretty well
we're making pretty good time this you know i think i i i kind of was like all right gotta be
ready joseph it's gonna be a big episode get ready because last year was so intense but i think this
year with a lot of write-ups it's mostly just sort of covering the the main takeaways from the
vulnerabilities and then kind of moving into the next one so yeah and on top of that i think it helps
that we've covered so many of these i don't know maybe that was something you all did last year but
yeah maybe it was less so yeah dude we've covered and i think we've covered like at least seven out of
ten of these before yeah over half for sure yeah so speaking of that we covered uh this number seven
which is arbitrary javascript execution in pdf.js we covered that in episode 72 so if you want to go
back and kind of get a little bit more of a deep dive on that you can um but the the tldr of this
write-up is that uh the author is providing a pdf to a library called pdf.js which i believe is the
um default library used in firefox to render pdfs if you just open it up in your browser
and um i think this is a really cool technique a really cool um way to kind of go a little a layer
deeper um by by working with a file type that isn't like typically considered to be web stuff you know
you got like hdml svg you know xml or whatever um and some of all these web types um but pdf is something
you kind of think of more as a file and he kind of goes in there and analyzes how this this js library
is parsing that out um at a lower level uh which i think is is very applicable takeaway for anybody
who wants to do research um and what he kind of stumbles upon is that uh this pdf.js sometimes it
relies on um the browser to render specific fonts but other times um the the pdf.js is responsible
it itself to render these glyphs and let me explain what a glyph is really quick a glyph is a a path
that should be drawn to represent a character right so um you know if you're doing an i the path will
have like a little dot at the top and then it'll have a space and then a you know a line if it's a
lower lowercase i um and that is represented by you know however the specific font represents that um
and pdf.js is responsible for rendering those glyphs in some scenarios and so what it did to
do that was it would create a javascript function which would render that specific glyph um and and
and when it did that it passed a a piece of the pdf that you that you supplied um into the new function
um call right new space function and then you kind of call it uh which is the function object constructor
um which is essentially eval uh if that function gets called um and so this is i think is an
underrated sync uh new function and who knows whether it's being used very very often but um
the parameter you pass into that is just raw javascript code and then it gets kind of can we do
it can we do a github search to find out if it's used like in like open source stuff yeah i'm sure it'd be
all over the place and it's just one of those ones that's just not very high profile you know
um so that's that was one takeaway for me um and the other takeaway was uh sort of got from this quote
it said if we instrument the pdf.js code to log these generated uh function objects then we can see
so on and so forth right so it's clear here that they have set up a an environment where they are
debugging this which is not very hard to do in the browser when you're dealing with js libraries right
you've got dev tools all set up you don't have to worry about hooking into like a debug or anything
like that the js engine is already you know debugged by dev tools um and it's just cool that they are
you know making sure that those breakpoints are set and kind of jumping into this and when when you go
back and you look at it it's like wow this is so simple you know um but it definitely took that extra
mile of like let me identify this non-traditional sync and sort of trace through all of this pdf.js code
to see where um the the sync is used yeah two quick things one speaking of dev tools you just did a
master class for critical thinkers so if anybody hasn't watched that they can go watch it or sign
up and go watch it if they're not currently one um but on the second thing i was curious so does this
execute in the context of the web page so if they're browser if they're rendering it is it going to
actually execute with the full control of the cookies of the page that's loading it yeah it is and and
when you open up a local um pdf as well uh this is in firefox then it will execute with the file
handler um yeah i saw that what access does the file handler have it's it's got a lot of stuff i
think there were some some things uh that were a little bit different here let me see if i can
jump in here interestingly enough this is not a file path you see in the url bar if you're downloading
the file instead pdf.js runs under the origin resource pdf.js okay so it's a resource file this
recents access to local files but is slightly more privileged in other aspects for example it is
possible to invoke a file download even to download arbitrary file urls um so it's it's a pretty
privileged context that this executed in inside of firefox um so very cool that's kind that's kind of
neat because i feel like i when i read this and especially when we were talking about it i'm thinking
like oh if there's a website that's a pdf.js that's rendering the pdf like that's where the vulnerability is
but this is interesting because if you have file upload on a company's website or whatever and
generally and if the application itself is like commonly using pdfs you know like let's say you're
a shipper and you're uploading shipping labels or something right if you uploaded a malicious one
where employees would download and then open especially right there in firefox that they're
already using this would have some pretty big impact i want did they say yeah it's a cve so it was it
was it's all fixed unfortunately but you know if in firefox if they're using an older version of
firefox it definitely could be impactful um sure or if you find or if you find something similar in a
different library or what have you so yeah the the other thing here is like when you're when you're
looking at this write-up it the way that they outline the code is really clear and i'm sure it was like
obfuscated and had a bunch of like other stuff surrounding it but the way that they output this um
this code block is like wow yeah that seems like a vulnerability um uh but one of the things that would
have caught me up a little bit is like they pass an integer into this into this function right um a function
constructor and that gets passed as an integer into the the resulting function um and they needed it
to be a string um for it to go into the javascript like that uh and be be rendered as a variable and
why don't you why don't you share your screen just i know that production loves us to do that a little bit
more and that that font matrix code uh block there is like pretty neat oh yeah for sure let me let me do
that okay um so down here down here at the bottom right here you can see um the this is the output of
the function right here this c.transform and there's integers being passed into this which originate from
this font matrix thing um but originally it looked like let's see if i can find the one originally it
looked like this right um so these were all integers uh being passed in um and for them to one of the
things that would have caught me up a little bit is that inside of the pdf i'm like ah how do i even
render a string um and apparently in pdf strings are rendered with um parentheses uh not double quotes so
this uh parentheses foo bar here that ends up getting put inside the the function body is this is the
representation of a string inside of uh you know pdf language um right and so i i just like how they
sort of went deep in on this uh this whole pdf um structure and understood all the various primitives
and types that they have um and then utilize that and the difference between that and and the javascript
code here um to to get a really crazy bug that was really reminiscent of a of a bunch of like flash
related vulnerabilities and stuff like that yeah that's interesting i'm sure they've probably looked
into it but i'll be curious if this exists and like other functions in here yeah yeah for sure
um this one number six is called double click jacking a new era of ui redressing um and dude like we've
covered this on the podcast before i kind of love this research but it's kind of like a little meh i don't
know so first let me just start by saying if you click on the link to go to this website um which will link in
the description at the at the very top of that page i'm gonna and i'll share my screen now um at the
very top of that page there's this uh little bar right here right where you can press play and hear
a podcast generated by notebook lm explaining this whole flow and dude we're cooked we're cooked man it's
a good podcast like i was sitting there reading through it and listening to it and i'm like oh my gosh
this thing is so good yeah i do a little bit of ai consulting for businesses to help them know how
to implement it ai and that's like the the biggest thing that blows their mind so i'm just like going
through it and then i say oh and by the way i generated this podcast about your company and what
you sell and what you do and they start listening to it and they're like wait what it's like i really
wish that google would at least how they do such great like speech or text to speech where it sounds so
natural the podcast i would sound like completely real yeah they hand off back and forth it's it's
like it's pretty crazy so yeah we're definitely cooked yeah exactly so anyway that was a little
scary but uh after i moved past that and and uh you know came out of the fetal position you didn't
double click the play button i did i would never double click anything i would never double click
anything ever again um because what this research is talking about you see you see that transition that
was a good transition there um is how you can harvest double clicks essentially to uh perform
c-serfs uh within an application so uh we covered this on the pod a little bit before so i'm not going
to spend too long on it but as a refresher for you guys um the flow of the the you know attack sort of
goes like this and this this by the way is sort of what i'm talking about when i say security research
right like this i think is more security researchy than some of these write-ups that that are here even
though the write-ups are like mind-bogglingly good because this is a new attack right um and so
anyway how this works is you get two windows open so that requires one click anyway right you click to
open a button um and now you're you're in the second tab uh and as as the second tab you have the
reference to opener and you can redirect opener to a page that will have negative impact on the user
if one button is clicked on that page um the traditional example for this one that he uses in the
blog post is like an uh authorization endpoint where you're saying like yeah i'll install this app on
my shopify store or like yeah i authorize you know this user to have all my data um and it's just accept
and then you do that and it's done right um and so then what the what the attacker does is you know
they pop up a capture or whatever and say hey double click here to uh incur you know to bypass the the
capture and so on the mouse down event which is the first thing that happens when you're clicking
um it closes the window and then you've got sort of like a little like a beat of the mouse up right
and then when you press down again for the for the second aspect of the double click now you're you're
focused on the window that was uh the opener of the window that you were intending to click on
um which has now been redirected to that uh that app um does it actually happen that fast in a lot of apps
like the the first window receiving the command from the second window reloads on this new
authorization page fast enough that the second click happens quick it's not it's not a reload thing
because that's why you need two tabs open so as soon as you're in that second tab you redirect the
first tab to got it so it's waiting it's just sitting there waiting fully loaded ready to go right so
and then on the on the attackers tab you know you put the double the button they need to double click you
put it right at the correct index oh of course so that like as soon as you close the page they're
hovering their mouse is sort of hovering right over the approve you know or accept button um and then
it's just really funny thinking that like slow computers where chrome is most of the ram when
they click the button to close the first tab it takes the computer like three seconds for the tab to
close so the second thing still happens on the first tab and nothing you know i'm running like 128
gigabyte server that i'm talking on right now and it still does that sometimes i don't know when you close the
tab it just hangs for a second yeah yeah it's nuts um but but it's a cool technique and it's really cool
yeah and i and i think um you know as far as takeaways from this go because we're trying to give
technical takeaways for each of these um the the technical takeaway is that uh whenever there's like
one single point of failure one click is a single point of failure in an application um this is a
technique that could be used and yeah so is is the first gadget something like client-side like post message
that that would is like like what what enables the attacker to load that second page with the
reference back to the first it's just window.open so so like you on an attacker-controlled page
like you do a when you get a click you know and that does a window.open so now you've got two
attacker-controlled pages open right and then you redirect the first one to the victim site which you
could do yeah yeah which you can do because it's all they have to do is be logged into the app that
you're trying to attack there's no other gadget that you need besides like one click to take over an
account right um wow so it's pretty impactful and what he says is most have chosen to address it
while some have have not you know that's a quote from the article is saying like these companies have
typically accepted this report and addressed it in one way or the other now what he didn't say is like
is there a wallet connects is there a wallet connect for one push for one clicks you're laughing no i'm
being dead serious that's where the most impact is spinning right now no no no yeah well one you're right
i didn't realize that double click jacking required basically nothing other than the fact that there's
like a state chain or an important thing that requires you to click through but that's really
common these days because your browser already has like a session for google and a session for
github and a session for discord because you're like long lived across all of them exactly so there
are so many things that are one click to connect yeah so it just it's kind of surprising to me yeah 100
i mean to be honest like typically something that requires one click and then a double click i would be
like that's a little bit i don't know like as far as user and action required goes but i mean
the impact is there you know like and it's who isn't going to do it who doesn't double click on a
captcha you know if it says double click here right it looks like especially if it looks like the cloud
flare one you know the one that pops up where it just requires one click yeah if they change it to
double click it would not surprise me in the least oh 100 um so anyway the other thing i really liked
about this one was he did provide a pretty reasonable method to prevent this from happening which is
on your single point of failure pages right um you should disable all buttons unless a mouse
move event has occurred because there's no mass move event when you're double clicking right you just
are on that page and you're clicking there's no movement yeah um so it's a pretty actionable thing
to put on a page that's pretty high impact from a security perspective to your organization so i could
definitely see some companies addressing this and um and and actually paying out a bounty for it yeah
honestly that would probably help with some of the automation based stuff too just like detect real
users yeah so all right um so you got three in a row by the way so yeah so sort of but we're actually
going to skip this one the the number five is um exploring the dumb purify library by kevin mizu and
we literally just did a whole episode on this like two weeks with kevin yeah it's not like you and i
covered it no you had the author two hour long episode uh with the man himself so go listen to episode
uh 111 if you want to get to it and i will say it's a little bit of a cop-out uh because uh on that
episode we technically covered the second article and this is the first article um but i think the
second article is more applicable for bug hunters anyway and this is another scenario where it's like
here's a write-up of a bunch of vulnerabilities in dom purify um which is is great and definitely you
know an amazing write-up um but it's not like here are a bunch of techniques that you can use to to
attack an application that are um you know a new vulnerability class or something like that um what i will
say however joseph is that after looking at dom purify for two hours with kevin in that episode
and kind of thoroughly understanding how the flow of of html sanitizers go by reading this blog post
and his second blog post yeah i find myself a lot more interested in html sanitizers so like i recently
have an html injection it's but it's like you know benign html injection on a google page and i was like
hmm well let me just take a look at like how the sanitizer is working right and i go in there and
i'm figuring out like oh these are the attributes i have access to these are the tags i have access
to you know what namespaces are these all in you know like how are these attributes being parsed and
processed is there any um you know replacement that's happening post sanitization that could allow you
know these attributes or namespaces to change um where the uses of regex versus like you know built-in
browser um dom parsing functionalities so um there there's there's there's a lot of stuff that can be
learned from that and uh the the dom purify write-ups uh will really help you address html sanitizers
from a higher level um by looking at a case study of how kevin does that specifically for dom purify
yeah actually i think that i have in my notes i even think i send it to you once i'm going to pull
out my notes right now like just my own bug bounty notes um i think i had a list of the different um
ways that a comment in html parsers could be um could be parsed and i had like a list of payloads
that i may have sent you yeah i still have my conversation from to ryan x the healthy outlet
right here and um i i think i cleaned this up but uh yeah i'll send this to you and then also we can
drop it in the in the show notes or in the ct in the critical thinkers chat later send it over we'll
we'll find somewhere to put it sweet just because i think that gives users something really nice
especially when you're talking about uh what you see is what you get editor you can paste all these
in there as one block and then just like if any of them parts weirdly it's almost like a single
payload in the same way you would look for like an xss polyglot very nice yeah there's like those those
xss payload lists as well you just paste in and you're like oh that was weird that's the one i'm
going to investigate exactly yeah all right so number four worst fit hit me with it joseph yeah
well i was gonna say i appreciate you giving me first pick because i went for this one i do have
to know would you have picked it oh yeah dude yeah this is a great one this is awesome okay i feel like
it's the coolest one i feel like this should have been number one but maybe maybe i just love uh
transformations yeah so you know if anyone is listening and they haven't read orange's uh worst fit
research you need to go read it right now just search for worst fit which is you know such a cool
name too because the algorithm is called uh best fit right that's right um so anyways i appreciate
justin giving me first pick because i picked this one immediately um have you since researching this
have you used these anywhere like have you looked for oh you have yeah i actually have gotten it to
work too yeah it was it was actually popped a bug with it yeah yeah i did it was super cool and and uh
yeah the did they use the yen they use the inside yeah nothing yeah dude it's like it's so cool when it
works too dude no you thread the needle yeah that's sick yeah i uh i'm excited about this um you know
people obviously know you have a lot of connection to to japan what people may not know is that i'm kind
of connected to korea because we have two two of our kids two of our three are adopted from south korea
um so that's pretty sweet and actually this is actually a crazy story i'm gonna tell it
and burn the extra 30 seconds because everyone will think it's really interesting go for it um my son who
was six years old actually you might not even know this story justin it's kind of crazy uh was a part
of this promotion when he was in korea before he was adopted called letters from angels where they
bring k-pop celebrity stars and pair them with the babies and have them pose for a photo shoot and
samuel's was not only picked as the baby but then his photo was like on the front of marie claire magazine
dude and was shown on like on the news and on tv in korea and uh the way we found out it's really
funny too my wife was just like in like a facebook group for like other families from korea yeah his
name is kong daniel so if anyone knows he like won the what's it called he won like the american idol
for korea like this was you know five years ago whatever um and so there's a picture of naked samuel
on the front of marie claire magazine and on and on the marie claire instagram dude that's like on
the internet and stuff if i can uh i don't know if i want to share a link we'll see but people can
find it now it's on the internet yeah so maybe we can just maybe we'll just share that's gonna
actually hear great someday you know when he's got a girlfriend you're like hey check out this picture
of it he's like dad shut up it is the coolest uh you know random fact or like two truths and a lie
yeah oh yeah oh my gosh yeah that's hilarious i was on front of a of a magazine as a baby wow yes
exactly uh here okay i'm gonna share my screen even though this is not about the episode at all okay
screen yeah what is going on yeah we're like we're like oh yeah this is going to be a tight episode uh and
then we go down these rabbit children dude what is that amazing that's amazing dude wow so cute yeah
so anyways uh all right my whole point is that i didn't know that there was like a career that
the wan symbol so for the like the yen symbol is the symbol for the main currency in japan but the
one symbol which is the main symbol for currency in korea is also a potential worst fit uh well so i'm
gonna start using that now and then what's out there the needle i'll let you know but um yeah so if
anyone has like just is wanting to jump straight to what's the most interesting what's the biggest
payoff here obviously orange i found a ridiculous you know level of impact with all these vulnerabilities
in a bunch of different ways um but one of the uh like kind of the tldr is that you should be using
these four symbols there is the full width double quote which toggles quote mode like what basically
navigate between places where quotes are often used to truncate strings or things like that
um and that is code point uff02 then there's the yen sign which will sometimes map to whenever it's in
best when it goes to the best fit algorithm to backslash and then the one sign which is the you
know the korean money symbol we were just talking about it also maps to backslash and so both the
inside and one sign and then the full width backslash can all be used to escape quotes or alter syntax so
yeah um yeah justin what are you guys like it's it's it's it's pretty crazy dude you know i i have
been using the double quote for a while because like i don't know if you've got your keyboard set
up for korean or how it works for that but like i've got my keyboard i can just like press windows key
space and it converts my my keyboard to like japanese and then i can type in japanese and so it's it's very
easy for me to just be like right hop into full width characters throw in the double quote you know and
push it through and i've actually been doing that with uh like less than signs and greater than signs
as well and they do pop sometimes um so so that's definitely like an easy thing to do just copy and
paste them in um so dude why exactly do the like why does a double width or why does a full width double
quote even exist like couldn't they just have used a normal double quote there yeah you know i don't know
when when i switch into the japanese mode on my keyboard it like all of the characters are double width
and like so for example if i hit a it'll show me the japanese character ah right but if i hit r it'll
show me a full width uh r you know roman character r and then i can either press o or u to make no or
du uh the the japanese you know um letters um and so i don't know i think it's got something to do with
like those just already being in like unicode mode for input but it makes it really easy for me to just put
in like full width double quote uh and and all that sort of stuff because i'm already sort of in
that unicode environment yeah so if you're typing in like a string and like the the text of the string
is japanese is it like full width double quote then this then all the japanese characters and then full
width double quote again is that kind of how it looks like on a web page or something yeah yeah it'll
render as a full width double quote even on the page so it's a different it's a different code point um
uh which is cool um and is where this uh this this comes into becoming a problem when it when it doesn't
fit uh when the best fit matching is like a sensitive character like a double quote or a backslash and and
the one that i've had the most success with so far is the whole like forcing the page to get rendered as a
uh as a like japanese uh character set and then the backslash becomes the yen sign and then you can just
sort of escape out of the the javascript because oh interesting backslashes yeah so that's pretty cool
that's cool yeah that is cool it makes me just i mean again amazed and i'm sure that everyone thinks
about this all the time but just unicode has caused so many security issues if there's like a standard
character set such that that never was invented it would have been so much better from a security
perspective because even with all the ai stuff with the with the piece i just put out right like
i included two tools that i put on my blog that you can go get to from the tools page and they're
both unicode related one is invisible unicode tags and the other one is like unicode emoji
variation selectors and so both of those are ways to basically encode you know a bunch of invisible
information on the page so anyways yeah pretty crazy stuff we did cover this one also
so in more depth on episode 103 so if you want to go back and listen to that one if you want more
information on this sweet um all right number three unveiling te.0 http request smuggling dude i'm glad
you chose this one because i i don't know man request smuggling i found it only like three or four times
yeah and it's it's just one of those vulnerabilities that i'm like i've seen i've i understand how it works
i just don't hunt for that and it and it's crazy because almost every live hack event someone comes with in
with a crit from request smuggling yeah it does feel like it expanded the scope of the types of
vulnerabilities to a much greater scale whenever this like set of vulnerabilities came out because
it can be present in so many different libraries and so many different configurations um and yeah so i
think in general one of the coolest things that they did here was basically look at all the existing
um smug request smuggling techniques and they asked the question like why not this other variation right
um and so the exact quote is right here they said the idea however we eventually asked ourselves why
is there no te.0 i'll actually share my screen so that the listener or that the viewers yeah because
there's like te.ct and ct.te or whatever but why not te.0 right so there's content length transfer
coding transfer encoding yeah and then um transfer encoding content length and then transfer encoding
transfer coding but then the content length which is treated the back back end ignores content
length header which is then treated zero but the front end parses it with cl zero so it's kind of
like why not do te zero which is just you know a cool idea and then um uh did you notice that the
thing they use to spin this up i'm sure that we talked about it uh or you all talked about it back
whenever http garden yes so it like you know we've talked a lot recently about how it's so easy to spin up
little things using ai like to have it right docker files or whatever but this is just a full force
multiplier in that regard oh yeah dude this thing is amazing i i definitely have seen this a couple
times i haven't used it yet but i think i mentioned it um right on the episode right after i met the guy
that wrote it at a google live hacking event and uh it was hilarious because he was just like and if you
look at the readme you'll you'll see what he's you know what it's like here but he was just like uh
catting just sending data with print f directly into netcat and that was how he was attacking web
servers right he wasn't using a proxy or anything he was just like print f to netcat and uh and then if
you look at the the um the you know readme on this thing they're doing something very similar so it's
very interesting yeah really cool stuff i specifically think that um research has all of a sudden become
accessible to a ton of people that it wasn't accessible to before with ai um i was talking
with kevin mizu to kind of like tie a bunch of threads together about um some different ways to do
prompt injection vulnerability specifically some ways you could potentially get xss if you can have
a large language model reply with like a really janky uh yeah like um mark down image link and
uh so he claims that he had he's like found this like it definitely works in some in some scenarios
i was not able to replicate it but the thing that i'm bringing up was it took me like five minutes
in cursor to just ask on it to give me an example like i was like you know make me an example html page
with um you know fake ai responses that are basically like this payload specifically and i gave it the
payload he had talked about where like you use you like escape some um you kind of make like a fake
image markdown link where you escape some stuff and you give like an on-air alert as a part of the
payload and um and i said but use like three or four of the most popular markdown image render um
libraries so that i can test all of them across to see which ones actually uh pop like which ones and
in like five minutes or well maybe less than five minutes it just wrote the html page and it wrote the
python script and then like and then so i was able to just open the html page in my browser and then i was
able to see what the output from that lm fake lm output would be had i gotten an lm to respond with
it and um that's it and that hit me with with this in the same way is it's like if you have this idea
so like i'm gonna go ahead and apply it to what we're just talking about we were talking about
worst fit right we were talking about those japanese characters the the one character the
yen character and then the two backslash or the double quote and then the backslash you could just ask
guy to basically um say hey i'm looking i'm trying to do some novel research in the area of the of
these parsers give me the you know i want you to render these four characters with the top five python
parsers and the top five javascript parsers and the top five ph php parsers and put it all on a single
html page where i can see if they do anything weird you know and you just like that's crazy like you can
do so many cool things like that today and i think that um people should do that so it's just all natural
language too you don't have to worry about any of these config files and stuff like that but htp
guarding kind of does that for us already exactly yeah my whole point there was like http guard makes
that even easier because it's gonna like stand up a bunch of example http servers that will you know
handle it differently um yeah i did think that google's bounty was kind of lame um since this was
actually this was vulnerable across like you know without a couple thousand or something um like the
the root cause of this one the te zero was it was vulnerable on a bunch of different bug bounty
platform or programs but the root cause was actually that there was a um google either iep and no they
were all either in gcp or google iep and it resulted in these these vulnerabilities and google's pretty good
about paying out stuff with like big impact and they paid 8 500 for this but i would have expected
something that was like cross a bunch of different um organizations a bunch of different tenants to have
paid more from them yeah 100 i i wonder i wonder what happened there i think it does get a little
bit difficult to show impact on these sort of things sometimes when you're not sure how the app is
actually used but um definitely you know i don't know in my my past experience google's been more than
fairs with bounties but i would have thought this one would definitely be well into the five-figure range
yeah and i think we had a similar um comment from the critical thinkers like i think a critical
thinker or two had a you know poor experience with with google i think a lot of it depends on what
you're reporting where you're reporting and then how you articulate yourself right i mean yeah yeah
we're pretty good about articulate ourselves and we also aren't hunting on like really tiny sandbox
things or what have you but yeah yeah another one of the members in the full-time hunter guild got a 75k
bounty though from google and got a um it was a 50k bounty and then a 25k bonus for a well-written report
yeah which is just nuts that they like this is one of the most well-kept secrets i think of the google
vrp like just look at the the about section and go into the rules and scroll down to like exceptional
report and just say like hey you need to include these two sections root cause analysis and um uh
remediation steps and if you if your report contains those two and it's a good report then now it's an
exceptional report and now your bounty is 1.5x and i'm like whoa who wouldn't do that yeah everyone's
gonna do that that's crazy well and that also makes their bounty payouts like so much crazier right
because they're already good but they're but 1.5 exit and it's like whoa you know do you know if they
still do that i was going to mention this to you your vulnerability that you just found that you don't
think will pay out that much um where it's like a crazy chain with like five different you know blockers
it would probably make for an amazing write-up they used to do like these huge bonuses for like really good
write-ups i feel like they discontinued it yeah they would reward the top five write-ups of the
year for google bounties my my buddy found i think like a 10k bug or something he's not a bug hunter
so it was really cool that he said that he like uh found this and submitted it but his write-up got
second overall and so he got like a 75 000 bonus and so i remember him just i remember him being like
flabbergasted five thousand dollar bonus yeah i think first gets 125 or 150. they're they're very generous
in that regard let me do they might not do it anymore but best write-ups google bug bounty dude
i i'm gonna put more effort into my reports if that's the case these are oh no no no reports
well it's the write-up like they they i think they want the publicity of it it's not they want you to
do a write-up on the buck yes yeah yeah it has to be a public write-up on the bug yeah hey i can do
that i could i got a podcast you know like like people will read it probably yeah seriously yeah no
jokes critical thinking podcast dot i o yeah um wow very cool man i didn't know that i gotta i gotta
talk to uh sam and martin about that because that would be like yeah so it was called 2021 gcp vrp
prize i'll share my screen so you can see it so it's the cloud which is now in scope uh they they they
have like their own official bug bounty team it's like in really great scope i shared the wrong thing
yeah they rock too i i've submitted a little bug to them recently and got like this huge they're
listening so uh shout out to y'all thank you for that that really awesome response in the report
they were like hey you know tell the team i said i said hey um so they definitely listen to the pod but
hey i'll move it over here yeah sorry i've got to pull up we can cut out this good it says i got a
little pop-up here that says joseph thacker's browser needs screen sharing permission so oh weird
um yeah so check this out what yes so this is 2021 i i assume it happened after this or maybe they just
continued it but yeah look they give first oh my gosh uh this and so this is just for the write-up so
this is like just to encourage security you know free churches to focus on gcp
uh no way 133k for first prize 73 look third prize this is my buddy my buddy mike no way third third and
second prize both get 73k yeah oh my god for just writing a good blog that's what's crazy but anyways
wow well definitely gonna suss that i gotta talk to the team about that um all right did you have
anything else on on uh te.0 of request smuggling or is that is that no sir let's jump to the top two
okay um so i guess hold on let's go back to that take away from that is is what you know easy to spin up
testing environments use your brain when no no no no not just use your brain listen justin this is a
good practical tip okay when you're when you're looking at a let's say a set of payloads a set of
functionality a set of connection types right you want to to make sure that you're comprehensive in
the different permutations you can get right yeah you're thorough right yeah so basically they noticed
that this look at request smuggling originally wasn't thorough it did not consider te.0 maybe it did and
you know who knows the port swigger team is amazing right i mean i'm sure they considered it maybe they
just didn't find anything that was exploitable in the moment or something um they're busy changing
the world so i mean yeah i think that that's the key point right is like think about all the different
happy paths or sad paths that can exist and make sure you test them all and don't just assume that
because one wasn't mentioned or one wasn't exploited yet that it was not exploitable true sure i like that
okay cool all right let's let's go to the number two here and then i'll let you take it away with
number one um number two dude this one was kind of the craziest i don't know this was crazy like when
i was reading this i was like wow uh really blown away and i think it was an interesting comment that
they had in the um the top 10 uh list i think uh james said something on lines of like kind of crazy
that uh this didn't get first place this year it just shows how how you know intense the competition
was but number two is sql injection isn't dead smuggling queries at the protocol level which was a
a defcon talk and write-up by ps paul um and essentially the concept behind this one was
um applying james kettle's sort of http desync research to different protocols and holy crap dude
like really james changed the world with that hp desync uh research in the first place because it
inspires crazy stuff like this um so what what this guy ps paul did here was he investigated um postgres
mongo um mysql and and a bunch of other sort of database um protocols and sort of investigated what's
going on there and is there some way that we uh can smuggle uh data in at the binary protocol level
the the protocol level where the you know programming language is communicating with the sql server
um in order to get sort of a smuggling sort of scenario and uh the way he did this is by manipulating
these uh binary protocol delimiters or term or terminators right so there's a couple main ways
that he outlines in the in the article and in the talk on on how these binary protocols are sort of
structured one a lot of times they have null bytes which are like the terminating characters
um two sometimes they have length based format so you'll you'll read like um you'll read like a
couple bytes and they'll be like okay the following 100 bytes or whatever are the payload so consider
that to be the payload and then it reads 100 bytes and then it's like another type delineator another
length and then the payload right and you can kind of get data across that way um and and that's kind
of what happened with these with these uh database binary protocols is they would have a length which
was an integer and then they would have you know a set of data and what the researcher found and what
all of this boils down to essentially is integer overflows in the libraries that are interacting with
these sql servers so specifically an integer overflow in the length part portion of these binary
protocols so if you send just an absolutely massive payload through to this sql server you know four
gigabytes about four gigabytes what will happen is the integer will overflow and become a really small
integer for the length right so when it goes to read the message it only reads like the first couple
characters of the message and then the data that then comes after that is no longer data but it's
actually a part of the binary protocol and then if you can structure it properly which he gave some
cool tips on doing then you can actually smuggle full uh sql queries into this binary protocol and induce
you know arbitrary sql statements which is kind of like sort of a stacked query sort of um sql injection
sort of scenario is this is there like a basically a no-op sled just like a traditional buffer overflow
like because if you're sending a four gigabyte thing and somewhere in there there's going to be
something you wanted to execute but it's probably quite small like a like a single query would be
tiny right so i wonder if there's like the basically a no-op sled oh there is yeah crafting a
payload and no sled yeah yeah an up sled um of that for sure and and they actually had a similar sort
of concept in there that wasn't exactly an ops sled um but it was sort of similar for the binary
protocol itself yeah um so yeah that was really cool really awesome research here and one little
tidbit about 27 minutes into the video was um a section that was entitled uh tips for sending big
data to web apps okay and i thought that was so valuable because he kind of gives a couple tips here
it says okay when you're dealing with sending four gigabytes to a web app like it takes a lot of time
and a lot you know you'd expect some component along the way to sort of fail right yeah for sure
right and so he gives some advice for for getting around it and one of the ones that i thought was
great was just use compression uh if the web server that's parsing it on the back end you know let's say
you've got nginx in front of like a web server right it nginx is only going to look at the content
length before it freaks out and says i can't i can't deal with this big payload right so if you can
compress your data via gzip and just send that in like as a header and then send it through if you
have a massive knob slide it's going to compress to something tiny absolutely yeah 100 and uh and
and so a very repetitive data um and so using that compression can allow you to get through like
layers of middleware um and so that that applies to like the reverse proxy sort of scenario but also to
the web sockets scenario um because web sockets also have some uh native compression that are
associated with a lot of the servers that um host web sockets um connections so very cool um
the other two here the other two here were use alternative body types so maybe send like uh
what's the so you've got like xform url encoded you've got json and then there's like the mime uh i
can't remember the name of it multi-part that's what it is yeah um sometimes that has has bigger
limitations or um more generous limitations on it and then also he said try to find some
way to do server-side creation of this massive string you know is there some way that you can run
you know some a programming language or something where it will output a massive string and store it
in the database uh if there is then you might be able to use that to create this massive string on
the server side then you don't have to worry about all of that sort of http middleware so i i i think as
as you know larger payloads become more impactful um and and have more of a place in web app testing
you know as this sort of demonstrated here i think those tips are going to be really really valuable
so could the payload i assumed based on the way when i read it that it had to be like kind of like
binary-ish data like that you were like really constructing some like uh unique payloads but if he's
saying you could generate a big string server-side via some web app presumably there's some way to do
this with just like ascii data or like unicode plus ascii right yeah yeah yeah presumably um i didn't
get to he didn't really elaborate on that point but it would have to be pretty granular the actual
exploitation piece but maybe you know a smaller piece could be um very granularly user controlled and
then you know the rest could just be inflation of the data so to speak that makes the overflow occur and
then you know you sort of are dealing with a smaller section of actually functional data and that
gets executed before hitting all that junk which just causes the server to ignore the rest of it yeah
so very very cool stuff i wonder the last time sql injection was a top three in any or top two for
example in any uh poor swig or top ten it's probably been a while yeah sql engine i mean this is he says
sql injection i don't even this isn't i don't know what this is but uh it's not quite the normal sql
injection all righty man number one we got confusion attacks this is orange and it and it's yours and it's
not mine and i'm glad because it looks complex but what have we got here yeah so basically like usual
orange went super deep on something in this case instead of it being unicode specifically the the big
thing you know the the big key point here that unlocks a lot of this is the question mark and so
um i think that some hacker needs to make it their identity to basically be like the joker from the
very old batman with the question marks all over it you know like that needs to be your stick we need
some uh some buck hunter to like make that their stick but um but yeah i mean he goes into extreme
extreme depth but the point of it is that there's a lot of middleware you know again we're really looking
in a secondary context here it's a lot of rewrite rules it's a lot of nginx rules um and some of
them are really interesting and it makes me want to do exactly what we're just talking about right use
that http garden to kind of see how these get handled differently um and it always makes me wish i could
be omniscient and just look at the config files across like all the bug bounty programs to like
correct for like this specific string like are there rewrite rules with dollar sign one right
because it's rewriting that little path and so yeah let me um i'll share my screen but dude it's
crazy whenever i i see these write-ups like this and and the payload is so simple he's like yeah
and then i just put percent 3f in there and i'm just like what yes and then just the right in the
right just the right place and so it's always like really hard to know if if he came to it top down or
bottom up it's like is he checking everything and he happens to find these one things or is he at the
bottom standing he's up doing code review and finding them from from you know the bottom up probably
probably more the latter but um but yeah super interesting stuff right um basically the issue
is that there's like you know weirder places that are going on with these rewrite rules that allow
you to to kind of pop these different vulnerabilities um and scroll scroll down a little bit on this the
one that blows my mind is at the bottom here right right at the bottom of your screen right there with
the server upload it it says curl server slash upload slash one dot gif and inside the gif you know
there's a there's a php payload and then he just adds to the end of that payload uh percent three f
o o dot php and then it renders as a as a php file and i'm like oh my god this is nuts yeah so genius
right and i'm sure some of us try little things like this here and there but it seems like orange
knows exactly where to try it oh yeah he's hunting with um with actual like full vision and the rest of
us are hunting hunting blind um but um yeah so there's a bunch of cool stuff in here i i wrote
down a few different things one is um on the path truncation part so um there's a bunch of
different um like primitives where you know paths are getting truncated because of the percent three
f i was going to ask you if you remember when you looked at this or if you have like some sort of
sniffer like whenever you're testing like what is your smell for if a truncation is actually occurring
because i think there's so many times whenever you put a encoded character like percent three f
uh percent o percent o a and it just like four hundreds or at four or fours and like in like a
weird way and my inclination i have a hard time knowing if that's interesting or not sometimes i'll
continue looking at it sometimes i won't and because like if it's interpreting percent like let's just
say it's percent two f so it's i'm you know i'm using a slash or and i'm throwing in some percent two
e's if it's not ever being normalized on the back end then of course it would 404 because who's going to
name their file space slash space slash right and so um and so anyways i didn't know if you had some
advice or some practical kind of like the takeaways that would that helps you whenever you're in those
situations yeah to be honest dude i mean as a client-side hacker i actually look at this sort
of thing a lot right like path normalization and like trying to smuggle past checks like this it's super
helpful and you know orange uses it here more in a client-side perspective but um there's a lot of
scenarios where if the client if the server will parse a percent 2f like a raw percent 2f not like a
a um decoded percent 2f as like a path delimiter that's a crazy gadget and and so same thing with
like the percent 3f right with question mark if if it is truncating the path at that specific point
and and that is becoming a query then that is a major gadget in your in your toolkit and actually i
definitely i'm going to add it to my to-do list right now for kaido because i really want to create
a little kaido plugin is super easy with workflows um plug in to detect these sort of things right
because it should be super easy to just send slash you know to one of them and then percent 2f and if
you get the same response back then it's parsing percent 2f as a as a slash you know um and and same
same thing with like uh the no it's trying my to-do this app is parsing the percent as a uh as a label
um but yeah it's it's uh it's a very easy gadget to identify and uh it has so many different purposes
across all of the uh of the application um and it's pretty common i think i found it many times
yeah exactly yeah i mean it doesn't surprise me at all whenever i have a server that interprets percent
2f as a slash like you said it's very and yeah yeah very common um so i mean obviously it's extremely
deep we're not going to go through all of it in particular but one thing that i have talked with
you about before we went live that i thought was really interesting was this symlink um i think it's
actually easy to find if you go to symbolic link so i'm going to read a little bit of this and then
justin can break it down or i can or i can break it down as well but i was i was really curious about
uh this section right here so it says to wrap up our gel rake primitive let's showcase how to perform an
rce using a double hop symbolic link and so one that just sounds really cool but what a badass right
exactly uh but but two i was like kind of confused how it worked and so um you know here is his final
payload and then here are the two symlinks that he's showing you exist in order to get to this
payload so do you mind to break down how this works yeah yeah so the takeaway from this that i got was
depending on the configuration in apache and hdpd um it will follow simworks and sometimes you're
locked into a specific directory because of where the the um document root is or or where this thing
is is uh pointing back to um but there's this really handy thing called sim links that will allow
you to just jump into different directories right and then you know when when you're in an environment
where um there are very far nested folders and and simply sort of nested down like there was in this
specific instance for redmine um you can kind of chain those together so hit a simlink now you're in a
different directory find a sim link in that directory hit that sim link and now you're in a
different directory and then you can you know go down until you find uh in this scenario he was able
to leak a secret key um so it's just a gadget for getting access to documents that are in a different
directory that you're not normally scoped to because at the end of the day all these traditional
web servers like um nginx and apache all they are is just exposing the file system right over http
um and that's kind of what he's taken advantage of here is using a sort of a file system um technique
right uh symbolic links and and utilizing that to jump around within the file system even that's though
that's outside of his uh scope directory yeah so in this case the secret key lives inside of etsy redmine
default and so we will have we don't have access to that so then he was able to basically go to um
you know you want to get here so you go to var lib red mine config and that's why this config is here
because var lib red mine gets overwritten by this sim link so you actually browse to this one place
that you have access to which is uh you know html user share red mine instances and then that gets
overwritten to var lib red mine yeah this is impossible to represent in an audio format so oh sorry for
anyone listening on youtube that are that are trying to follow with this there's like several sim links
um that and essentially it just uh dumps us in a directory where there's there's access to secret
stuff so yeah and i guess the big takeaway for anyone listening in audio is that i just never knew this
was really possible at like a html web app level like of course whenever you're whenever you like
get code execution in a sandbox you're trying to escape you're looking for siblings you're doing this like
this is like very normal stuff but i did not realize that you could basically construct a massive url
that included you know to a web app that actually included like a double sim link hop like this very
interesting stuff very interesting and it does require i'll read this this part right here it says
in debian ubuntu distributions of httpd the follow sim links option is explicitly enabled by default love it
but even in non-debian ubuntu versions apache http server also implicitly allows them
uh allows symbolic links by default and then it provides a very common uh apache snippet that i've
seen time and time again with the options follow sim links um uh directive so uh very cool stuff there
um definitely going to keep that in mind if i'm ever sort of in that environment where i'm scoped to
a a specific directory and try to have access to the file system to find these uh symbolic links
uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh